now it is time once again for our puppy
pig skin picks
brought to you by subaru las vegas and
the animal foundation john you brought
another
ferocious canine with you we've really
got to talk about this at some point
here who
who do we have in your hand then this is
rosie rosie she's six years old
i think she'll make a wonderful guard
dog guard dog oh yeah
tell us about rosie uh how she gets
along with other animals and just with
humans she's been very friendly since
she got here
she's she's really really affectionate
she wants human companionship
she stuck to me she's stuck to christy
um she's just a great dog
i forgot to say she's only five pounds
so pretty obvious
um we should also also mention the uh
best in show which is still going on
viable foundation yes
it is sunday the 15th but voting is
going on right now and the public can go
on to the website
to the animalfoundation.com and vote for
the best and show dog right now
excellent and you can also buy tickets
which is good it always goes to a good
cause tickets are
20 20 20 donation excellent so it all
goes toward the dogs
all right well let's uh rosie it is time
for rosie don't fall asleep here buddy
it's time for the puppy pig skin picks
here we've got the
denver broncos and the las vegas raiders
rosie wanted to put you down there and
you can make your selection here
a vital choice oh thinking about it
goes for the denver broncos rosie will
have to have a discussion about this
later on
if you would like to adopt the ferocious
rosie call the animal foundation later
today the numbers on your screen
702-955-5901
you do have to make an appointment ahead
of time though and
that's how you'll get your hands on
rosie good dog
good dog